Ashley you marry
me yes former bachelorette Ashley Hebert
and her husband JP rosenbom have called
it quits after nearly eight years of
marriage the two announced the news on
Instagram Wednesday Ash posted this pick
and wrote in part quote it is with a
heavy heart that I share with you that
after month months of Separation JP and
I have amicably decided to go our
separate ways we created the most
beautiful children and shared memories
that will never be forgotten our
differences have taken a toll on our
relationship and after years of
attempting to repair the damage we've
decided that it is in our family's best
interest to create new and separate
lives for our children the 35-year-old
dentist concluded her post asking fans
to respect their privacy adding that
their ultimate focus is creating a
stable and healthy life for their
children JP will you accept the last and
final
Rose I love you so much
baby JP shared a separate message with
fans writing in part quote please please
please know that there is no one to
blame that there's no event that
triggered this decision that no one is
the victim and that we've done
absolutely everything we possibly can to
try and Salvage this marriage I know
that I told you that my biggest fear is
falling in love with you and having my
heart broken again
and I'm still
afraid I don't think about all this I
don't think about now I think about
forever and it's hard to know JP
proposed to Ashley on her season finale
of The Bachelorette in
2011 I'm so in love with
you you're the one you're it
and they tied the knot in a televised
wedding in December
2012 ladies and gentlemen it is my honor
to announce to you Mr and Mrs
rosenbom the pair share two children a
six-year-old son Ford and a
three-year-old daughter Essie and they
even recently appeared on The Bachelor
the greatest seasons ever is there a
particular memory that stands out you
know what I do remember our first date I
was like oh I could actually be into the
sky like he was manly and like kind of
rugged I was into it and there was
definitely a connection there at that
time definitely it's undeniable the two
opened up about their life in Miami
unassured host Chris Harrison they were
doing well after JP was diagnosed with a
rare autoimmune disorder guon BR
syndrome last year doing good great
we're holding
up we're we're faking it we're we're
going crazy with homeschooling and it's
uh Weighing on us but uh we're we're
holding steady
m